je vous le disais dans les titres dès
lundi tous les élèves du primaire au
lycée devront être protégée par un
masque chirurgical ou deux catégories
une une nouvelle règle afin de mieux se
protéger contre les variants du coc vide
fini donc les masque en tissu fait main
de son côté la fcpe réclame des masques
gratuits qui va vérifier l'homologation
de ces masques et qu'en pensent les
parents concernés éléments de réponse
dans ce reportage de lucas chopin dès
lundi à l'école depuis le cp et jusqu'à
la terminale la règle change
fini les masques fait maison seuls
autorisés les masques chirurgicaux et de
catégorie 1
du côté des parents on accueille la
nouvelle avec résilience sur nico n'est
pas tout c'est pour ça s'est imposé donc
de toutes façons on s'adapte en il faut
juste trouver les masques pouvoir se
procurer les masques et c'est soulant
masque chirurgical en petit format pour
les trouver oui on va acheter des
masques chirurgicaux
on va faire ce qu'il faudra pour tomber
malade ces nouvelles mesures annoncées
en début de semaine vise à ralentir la
progression du variant anglais les
masques de catégorie un filtre 90 % des
particules dangereuses et sont
trouvables en grande surface à l'entrée
des écoles le directeur sera bientôt
chargé de vérifier la qualité des
masques des élèves
il devra prendre des mesures en cas de
manquement il pourra lui fournir un
masque de secours il précisera aussi à
la famille bien sûr qu'il faudra qu'elle
n'oublie pas pour le lendemain de ce
pour procurer le masque en question par
contre si on a pas on est en rupture de
stock n'a pas les masques mailly fo
drame isolé l'élève certains syndicats
de parents d'élèves s'opposent déjà à
cette obligation
la fcpe réclame de nouvelles
distributions gratuites de masques dans
les écoles